I quote I did not think about pulling  the trigger as soon as I had the noise  before i could think I i live on  something pulled the trigger clothes  coat the accused stated that he never  thought of the possibility that he could  kill people in the toilet he considered  however the thinking back  retrospectively it would be a  probability that someone could be killed  in the toilet he stated that if he  wanted to shoot the intruder he would  have shot high up and more in the  direction where the opening of the door  would be to the far right of the door  and at chest height I paused to state  that this accession is inconsistent with  that of someone who shot without  thinking I shall revert to this later in  my judgment